Louis ridic the ESPN NFL analyst joining
us from the Scouting Combine in
Indianapolis Louis thanks for joining us
how do you separate fact from fiction
with Tom Brady that's a great question
Tom does a great job right of concealing
and what is its true intentions Arminius
let's everybody out there kind of twist
around and throughout all these
different theories and teams come and go
as far as who's going to be the team
that's going to land them who's not
going to be the team that lands and he's
gonna go back to New England exactly go
back to New England yeah it's a it's a
mystery right now but I there's one
thing I do know then and that is the
people who I know who would have some
insight as to just how what really means
something to this guy really does
believe that this is this is not about
money this is really about respect it's
about making sure that he has the things
around him and people understand what he
needs to have around him at this point
in order for him to really play at his
highest level and I think that
ultimately is going to be where he winds
up going there's no way Tom's gonna go
to some place that's in the midst of
rebuilding something that doesn't have
the weapons he's never gonna go through
a season like he went through last year
again where you saw him game after game
look about it frustrated and his
exasperated as you've never seen him
look he's never going to go through that
again if you ran the Patriots let's say
you're Bill Belichick since he's the GM
as well like like what what are you
planning on doing what is plan a and
what's Plan B yeah yeah I think honestly
the best thing for the Patriots
investing for Thomas for those guys
ability reunite if they both want to
continue to win and in a way that
they're used to winning so if I'm if I'm
Bill I think I'm probably taking the
approach of being maybe more aggressive
and more forthright in terms of getting
the kinds of players to come to New
England that would that would help Tom
the best particular on all offense
without messing up anything else that
they're trying to do overall from an
overall team concept cuz you know tit
knows all about the team he's never
going to sacrifice what's best for the
team you know at the expense of trying
to just get one or two players but I
would be I would probably step outside
of my comfort zone and say hey look
we're going to do everything we can
and we're going to be upfront about it
as far as recruiting some players that
could come in here particularly on
offense and help you namely some weapons
on the perimeter which is something that
all of us could see last year they just
didn't have they just didn't have these
tribals Mohamed Sanu but Mohamed Sanu
was never going to be that guy they
tried with Antonio Brown you knew you
couldn't count on them is only a matter
of time and you know it's one of those
things that they need to be able to get
someone out there to really help him and
they need to assure him that they're
going to do everything they can to do
that they need a presence in the middle
of field something to replace Gronk
although it's never going to be like
Grodd they need that position that
position has been vital to Tom's career
and they need to make sure that they do
everything they can to do that so if I'm
bill I'm saying look this is what our
plan would be in order to try and make
sure that we never have a repeat of what
happened last year because really for
Tom to start over somewhere else I mean
I guess it's possible but there's so the
heat you know the Patriot Way is so
ingrained in him and he has helped
develop the Patriot way so much to the
point where I'm just wondering what he
thinks it'll be like somewhere else and
whether or not he can go ahead and make
another organization kind of operate the
way that he's used to because the way
he's used to operating has made him the
greatest winner of all time and that
that would be a tremendous shock to me I
mean I'm never gonna say I can think for
Tom Brady but there'd be a tremendous
shock to me and a tremendous risk for me
to take but okay so let's say Brady goes
elsewhere mm-hmm are you drafting or are
you bringing in a free agent I'm
bringing in better I'm bringing in
somebody who who I'm probably doing a
little bit of both okay I but I would be
trying to make sure I can bring in
somebody with a tremendously high IQ
that can get on the same page with Tom
quick in a very short amount of time
given that who knows what's going to
happen with this new CBA and how much
more practice time is going to be taken
away from coaches and players which is
something that people are kind of
forgetting now look some of these great
quarterbacks get ticked off during the
season when their guys aren't in the
right places are not able to gel with
them why do you think that happens that
happens because they practice football's
only game you get better at if you
practice so you better have the right
profile a player whether it's the draft
or a veteran and someone who can operate
again at his level
intellectually or close to it very
quickly so I think it's not just about
height weight speed it's about the right
kind of players that have that same kind
of over-the-top commitment to the game
that tom has I mean there's this see
there's so many things that go into it
and so much risk involved for them go to
go somewhere else I mean this really is
in my view all right
this - and the Redskins and I don't know
I mean it's not a report it's it's
actually happening that they met with
borough and and tua but could you see
this actually playing out if all the
medicals check out on to a Ron Rivera
going in and maybe drafting his
quarterback sure I mean we've seen it
before we've seen we've seen it over you
know during the during history you know
play out that way over the course of
history that people when they come over
come in and take over an organization
just inherently say it's anything that
was here before me is not mine and
therefore I'm just going to wipe the
slate clean and do things my way and
they get turned off to other players and
kind of like rubber stamp them in a
negative way and I think that could
possibly happen to Dwayne house because
rod could possibly you know just kind of
not take a liking to him hold last year
against them whatever whatever
terminology you want to use and start
over I think it'd be ridiculous I think
that would be totally throwing context
out the window as to just how this
functional that place was last year from
the get-go from the very first time that
it was announced that Dwayne Athens was
going to be their quarterback it started
leaking out immediately that he wasn't a
choice of the coaching staff and or the
choice of some people in the scouting
department and that it was Dan's choice
yeah you do those kind of things I'm
what do you thinks gonna happen to the
kid you think he's gonna always at that
young age show the right attitude and
the right work ethic in the right
demeanor of course he's not going to
when people just throw that stuff out
the window if they dressed to it and
they pass on chase young who I know for
a fact that the most important man in
that organization being the owner loved
I think it'd just be ridiculous I really
do but we'll see do you think chase
Young is the best player in the draft
I think at his best he is the best
player in the draft yet he can change a
football game and has shown he can
change it over and over and over again
in a way that making that very few other
players in this draft can do Joe Burrell
can change a football game because how
good he showed that this year - are you
sold on bro yeah I was drafted number
one overall over to us at that position
simply because the fact that he doesn't
have a durability history like to have
and you could you can say all you want
all things being equal I would take to
it and that would be the case for me the
fact the matter is they're not equal he
does have a history and it's not just
and a lot of that history is caused by
you know a little bit by him in terms of
maybe just not getting the ball out of
his hands past enough getting taking
some hits that he shouldn't take which
leads you know what increases the risk
of getting injured so there's some
things that are to his own doing but if
he was if he didn't have the hip issue
and he hadn't had two surgeries on his
on his ankles on his lower extremity I
would take him over Joe Burrell
quite honestly okay but chase taste is
the guy there's no doubt about that
we're talking to Louis Riddick ESPN NFL
analyst you can see the Scouting Combine
on ABC and ABC special that Louis will
be on from five til 6:00 p.m. Eastern
tomorrow also when you you look at these
40-yard dash times and and I know it's
for amusement only in my opinion but you
may think different because you know
your former player I want to know these
wide receivers you know these guys are
running for 240 nobody ever publicizes
how big their hands are which I find
interesting but also the other part is I
think this is more of a quickness game
than a speed game when you need to get
to from point A to point B because my
quarterback only has X number of seconds
to get rid of that ball I would rather
know I would rather take a quick guy
over a fast guy your thoughts on that
yeah sure I mean by position yes um you
know a lot of times short area quickness
is more or less the deciding factor in
terms of you being able to win or not
then actual long speed and to take it a
step further there's plenty of guys as
you were alluding to that are great on
the clock which is times
but they're functional speed with pads
on in a football game is not nearly the
same we've seen it over and over and
over again and we've seen add opposite
way guys who don't time very well in the
clock out loud Jerry Rice who goes on to
be the greatest player maybe in a pill
history how is it the Jerry never got
caught from behind Louis exactly that's
that that's the thing see there's
there's an art form to running the 40
there's so much that goes into it from
your start to your shoulder height when
you come out of the start to your stride
length to your staying relaxed all that
stuff and sometimes guys just don't feel
good when they run and it just doesn't
work out that way it doesn't work out
the way they want but Jarrod when he got
on the football field Jerry had
functional speed Jerry had functional
quickness the kind of things that you're
talking about and he was very smart he
knew angles he knew all that stuff and
hasn't played against him a few times I
can tell you this I never thought that
this was a guy who ran for six for seven
plus in the 40 he smoked everybody
everybody so but there's there's guys in
this drafted at wide receiver I will say
that these kids are fast this year but
Henry rugs from Alabama and runs the
third is a legit player he's just not a
flash in the pan who can just run a fast
40 this kid can flat-out play Jerry Judy
although he carries Judy runs four four
five yeah he's slow and people are like
he's he's the best route runner in the
draft by far by far he's dynamite so I
mean it's it's a quality draft this year
I know the 40 is dominating all the talk
but these kids who were running fast
they're also very very good players I
think it's the best draft I've seen in
20 years for vibrancy I love CD lamb
absolutely he's fantastic and he was one
of those he ran for five I know he
Gianna's on the field but on the field
when you're talking about quickness yeah
the ball in his hand he's electric he's
like a video game he just makes
something out of nothing and there were
two or three plays this year while I
watched and I went there was nothing
there there were four guys around him
and somehow he scored a touchdown yeah
Texas I'm in Texas
detective game comes to mind immediately
he's just very very good with the ball
in his hands great vision great
functional strength balance toughness I
mean all those things that you can't
merely measure here that really mean the
this is just a way to kind of get
comparison you know on a level playing
field so you have some way to sort these
guys athletically but you know I mean
you've watched the game forever you know
what really matters all right final
thing the show has a bet with Jeff
Darlington Jeff Darlington kind of
reporting that brady and he be stunned
if Brady went back to the Patriots a guy
on my show Paulie bet Darlington $500
they $500 goes to the Jimmy B foundation
whoever loses the bet are you on Team
Patrick or team Darlington Brady leaving
the Patriots well team Patrick says he
returns right yes come on team Patrick
okay I think ultimately he returns
there's too many things Tom's used to
structure discipline Lois all this talk
and then we don't like there's wishful
reporting that goes on likely yeah we we
want something to happen and you know
you get this feeling that maybe Phillip
Rivers to the Colts will be the big move
in the offseason here I don't know the
Colts the Colts may be in play for a lot
of things there's a guy named Jordan
Love who is creating a lot of buzz
around here keep his mane keep his name
I know I know
somebody's gonna fall in love Lois you
know how this works but it's like true
Biscay and Daniel Jones where you go
wait a minute where did that come from
and somebody might do that with Justin
Herbert or or love so it's happening as
we speak believe me if it's already
Valentine's Days a couple of weeks late
hey thanks for joining us Lois as always
we appreciate it
that's Lois Riddick former NFL player
mothership analyst ABC special from 5:00
to 6:00 Eastern tomorro live from the
NFL Scouting Combine in Indianapolis